most of society's rules and traditions
are based on when people were dying at
50 years old most of the rules of when
you should get married and what you
should do and what you should have
accomplished is literally based on the
last Century's DNA you are so young you
have every opportunity technology is
exploding at a speed where your life can
change in a minute on a decision and
literally literally the only thing that
is [__] you up is you worry about
what other people think about your life
do random [__] try new things you have
your whole life in front of you I
couldn't be happier for you if you're
standing right now you have a hundred
years to live that's actually how it's
going to work out for you and you need
to start acting like it